welcome to the tim dillon show everybody
special episode today we rarely do
guests but we're we're having this guy
on
yeah thank you so much yeah no it's
[ __ ] great to have you here we're an
odd pair
me and you i know people wouldn't think
really people wouldn't say people look
at me and look at you it looks like
it's like a big brother program where
i'm like trying to yeah you're trying to
like mentor me
yeah show me the right patch trying to
help you out except you you have so much
more money than i do with more fame
you know probably not yeah i'm like you
should go this way and you're like
naturally
you should relax and do what i do you
should get a face tattoo
yeah you should what um how many i'm
thinking about getting a tat for the
first time in my life
oh you don't have any tattoos i don't
have any tattoos oh wow what are you
gonna get
i don't know we're cause we're doing
this crazy tour me and my opener uh
dan and we're all over the it's a weird
time to do comedy because
like i'm doing anything we have time to
do anything like we're thinking about
um you know maybe getting something to
just commemorate this crazy [ __ ]
little tour of what we're doing and then
like because we do it
we end in mid-november so we have like
we go through the run-up to the election
the election and then a few weeks after
the election
we just [ __ ] don't know what it's
gonna be like to get up in front of a
room full of drunk
people oh man when shit's wild yeah i
wonder what is it what is that like i
mean you have a lot of experience you've
already already done that
yeah i've never done like i've been
doing it the last couple of weeks and
people are tense
are tense right now they're tense right
now because they haven't left their
houses
yeah and therefore they come out to the
comedy come out to the comedy club
this is like they're just going out
again and everybody's got real strong
feelings about the election my audience
is really divided
so i got people that are like trump's
gotta win again and then i got people
that are like trump's the devil
and then i put them in a room and then i
pour alcohol on them oh my god
and then i try to make them all laugh
for an hour and get it get away with my
life is there any like uh
crazier cities that you've been to the
more than others um
i think phoenix arizona was drunk they
were junkies
they were drunk and they were partying
and they also they don't think of it's
real at all
so no mass wearing they don't [ __ ]
they were coming afterwards trying to do
like a meet and greets after the show
and i'm like dude
it looks better they're just trying to
make like a meet and greet like they
were trying to just grab me and they're
like come on
and i'm like and it was fun but i mean
it's like it looks bad
yeah god forbid i get sick or they get
sick then i
the internet will go the internet tries
to cancel you if you aren't safe with
anything
yeah yeah yeah you've gone through that
a lot you've gone through
why do you think you're so controversial
people uh well i think
the most part my name uh little zan just
coming onto the scene it was just
already
what is the name is that what explain
the name well uh
back in austin texas what year was that
like 2000
2016 i was just uh
crazy off xanax i was i was trying to be
a photographer my camera had just gotten
stolen
and uh i remember we were on like main
street or something i just walked into
the liquor store
and my friend was like man you're always
high off xanax like
i'm gonna call you lil xan i didn't
think anything of it i was like that's
that's stupid but funny like right
that's the fun
it's just it's a fun development yeah
right and then uh from there on i wasn't
even thinking about making music but all
my friends made music so i got back
together
thinking about xanax yeah i was like
only xanax you know what i mean
and then uh yeah i got back to la and i
was like well just
all my friends make music let's see what
happens and just from there on the
controversy followed on
yeah yeah do you feel like a lot of
young people follow you
definitely a lot of a lot of young
female audience for the most part yeah
that is not this demo in this show
i'll tell you right now it's just crazy
yeah this is not
weird this is not a 19 year old girls
show
uh the women who come to my live shows
have all been to prison like that's the
type of woman
that the woman can listen to this voice
for hours on end
they love you though yeah they do like
me they do like me they do
so do you feel like your responsibility
to live a certain way because you're
like all these people
oh yeah yeah definitely uh more more and
less recently i had a little uh hospital
scare about like uh like five
six months ago i was sent to the
hospital i was trying to just quit
everything cold turkey uh
oxycodone and xanax mainly um
but i had five seizures and when one day
five seizures
and it's it put me in the hospital for a
couple weeks and i got out and i just
stayed clean because i was like
this is gonna kill me you know what i
mean yeah and i've been trying to i've
always
tried to be a good role model against an
advocate for
not taking drugs like i was i was never
like yo y'all got to be like me
and i was just letting people know that
you know we we go through this this
struggle
you're not alone and i i just recently
come off it and
this is the best i've felt in my whole
life you know yeah you look great oh
thank you you look like you're you're
you're
you know you feel like you're in you're
living yeah
it's like it's own type of high actually
just be this coherent you know what i
mean if we would have done this podcast
like a year a year and a half ago i
would
you would have been sleeping i would
have missed it yeah i would have been
yelling and you would have just been
would have been right here just like
yeah but yo now what do you feel like
is that better for creativity to to be
sober uh
i'm not i'm not gonna argue against
drugs like uh
they do help some sort of aspect of
creativity um but you could be just as
creative without drugs you know what i
mean you just gotta find
inspiration and find like a good balance
and you could be just as creative
why are there what like i'm sure i know
the answer because comedy there was so
many drugs and now there's not as many
because so many people died you know
like yeah
geraldo you know all these people that i
mean you could
you go back and there's there's a litany
of people that have died from drugs and
yeah being unhealthy and stuff what do
you think like a lot of the tragic
deaths
whether it's little people or mac miller
do you think they're making people
really
kind of think about how they're living
because these guys are so talented
yeah so much potential is this making
people think about stuff
i think it's definitely showing people
you know the repercussions and what what
you know what can happen you know it's a
shame that we lost
mac and peep and all them such talented
like [ __ ] artists dude
and young kids and young too you know
what i mean um just so much potential
um yeah i think it's definitely but if
you if you go back in time this is
always
people young people have always been
dying of drugs you know what i mean like
in the limelight
is what i'm saying uh i think it is
making people a little more aware
but man when you when you fall down that
rabbit hole of addicted to drugs and
stuff
it's hard to get out it's tough yeah i
mean i was i was an addict for 10 years
so like i
i started doing coke at 13. oh [ __ ] yeah
so yeah i was uh i was um yeah it was
bad it was bad from 13 to 25.
okay and on and off cocaine how did you
manage to get off of it i started doing
stand-up when i was 25 i bought a house
when i was like 22. cooked out of my
skull i got a subprime mortgage i bought
a 600 000 house the house was worth
maybe 350.
yeah and i mortgaged 600 because it was
back in the days when you could do that
and uh i was just every night i was just
drinking every night
coke you know drowning in debt
and um but i would tell people about it
they'd be laughing and i'd be like i'm
i'm saying the worst stuff
and they would just laugh oh like this
is really funny and i'm like this i'm
literally gonna die
and they were like this is really funny
and then i just was like oh i want to
maybe
start making people laugh and then i
just started doing that at 25 and i
sobered up and i've been sober i'm 35
now
it's about a decade so how how was the
the sobering up
it was tough but i you know i did
transfer addictions right yeah like from
from drugs to comedy like i did transfer
it yeah so instead of doing drugs i
would do comedy three or four times a
night like that was what
some people trace yeah it took your mind
off of it took my mind yeah something
like i had a friend got sober went into
fitness
yeah i did not do that but he did that
he went another way
uh i wanted to stand up and i was just
like you know i just got to stay
you know i plugged my head into another
world yeah that's a that's actually good
that you talking about that because
people
that is a big thing of if you want to
get help with addiction you got to find
something
else to occupy you know your mind and
stuff and that's like probably
the best advice you maybe can give
somebody is just find something else to
just something else to occupy your time
yeah if something you love or you're
passionate about it makes a big
difference i've seen a lot of people
like you said go into fitness
yeah that seems like that's a natural
high natural high you treat your body
the right like my opener is like
major in a fitness and that which i
didn't even know was a major but you
could
major in exercise in school i should
have gone to college i had no idea
um and and he he's he's great to have
around because he's like
you know every now and then he's like
you know he's like you gotta you gotta
reign it in a little bit you know try to
always respond to
well like we were at the store yesterday
and i got mad at him because he was like
i was like we should get all this ice
cream maybe little zanna will want ice
cream he's like
is that just an excuse for you to have
me up for you to get ice cubes yeah i
was like do you like ice cream
yeah see see yeah should i kind of smile
yeah we have cookies and cream though oh
yeah but so now what
what are you you're 24 are there people
from your life
because you were not a guy that when you
were growing up like me i think people
were probably like this guy's not going
to succeed oh i was the same way yeah
they're
the same way dude um if you saw me in my
early 20s
i was drunk cooked out yeah driving a
car with with no insurance
just bad like no my license has been
suspended it's still suspended like
yeah i mean i was just working in the
subprime mortgage office barely selling
those [ __ ]
for me it was uh i dropped out freshman
year after after attending three months
of high school i was like
three months of high school yeah wow
crazy three months of high school
yeah i couldn't do it you gave it till
halloween yeah and then we're just like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah the problem whoa
yeah the problem was the
the people i felt like i was trying too
hard to uh like fit in you know be the
cool kid
yeah and i was like man i i could tell
that i was becoming like something i
wasn't
right and i was just like i can't do
this i like to play video games right i
dropped out
spent probably the majority of what
would have been my high school
experience
playing video games not not talking to
girls i was like
you know were your parents like cool
with that or
oh man i mean they weren't cool with it
at first but i think they realized uh
pretty soon that they were like oh we
can't
tell him what to do you know right right
they're good parents good supportive
parents but um
they would have liked that if i probably
would have you know went to school but
finished ninth grade finished ninth
grade at least right i probably were as
supportive as it could be yeah
supportive
all right he gave it till thanksgiving
yeah let's let him play some games
and then uh i didn't really know what i
wanted to be
you know i just knew that i just didn't
need school for what i was getting you
just knew you weren't going to
conventional yeah i wasn't going the
community i knew that too and i don't
i don't i don't encourage people to like
go that route yeah we're not encouraging
anyone yeah
just in case our advertisers are
wondering we're not encouraging anybody
to drop out
yeah when you were
playing video games will you you just
love rap you love music oh i've loved uh
i had me and my dad used to just bump
records on like vinyl and awesome who
are the people that you love because i
know that there's been much made of like
you saying that like
certain rap didn't speak to you where
it's like you you know you respect guys
like tupac but you were like those were
my favorite guys you know yeah i have so
much respect for
all that like i grew up on old school
you know i grew up on like tribe called
quest de la
soul uh big l a lot of different things
you know um
yeah mad respect for that i dated foxy
brown for many years you did i'm kidding
so
i just say oh my god that's so cool
tell us right after she got out of the
firm no uh
so you you were like into rap though who
are you
who are your guys were you like when you
heard that you're like i want to do this
because for me it was like guys like
patrice o'neal
yeah and and bill hicks or george carlin
or even like a joan rivers like when i
heard
people say [ __ ] was like [ __ ] i cannot
believe they're saying that i can't
believe it's so funny who are your
people and rap we're like these are my
[ __ ] people
it's so crazy because i i didn't really
know
i wanted to pursue music right very
until very
like far into actually i mean uh but i
just always love music and it's not
necessarily just rap i grew up on
alternative rock like
uh grunge you know about smashing
pumpkins uh yeah yeah
all that stuff nirvana and but i think
around the time like uh
when i started to make music i started
to really appreciate the craft and all
that
and i was like oh this is just something
something really special and my love for
music like transitioned into
you know a cool little career off of
music yeah just
super sick but what was the first time
in your career that you knew things were
going in a good direction like you were
like [ __ ]
i'm actually yeah like yeah probably
like around
uh that's hard man uh was it like one
show
was your one thing where you got out
there and you're like [ __ ] like this is
i can do this for a living
uh well i was i was like a supporting
act for
my friends and a lot of other different
artists who were they like who are those
people uh my friend stephen cannon who's
still
uh he's on the rise and just people like
really that aren't really known
right it was kind of just i just love
performing it was like for like 10
people
you know it wasn't that crazy so i think
the first time in my career
was when i dropped my record betrayed on
cole bennett colbern it's a lyrical
lemonade platform great platform
and then it hit like a million plays and
i wasn't used to any like a million
anything spotify
on youtube on youtube on youtube i don't
even think spotify was really
uh like it was a thing but it wasn't
like really popping off yet
yeah and then it hit a million views in
like an hour and i was like what the
[ __ ] is wow yeah that's
huge it's a i'll never forget that
feeling it was it was
like magic you know what i mean like
yeah it's crazy man just yeah
that's probably the first time what
about are there other people
that you came up with where you're like
i owe that person a lot
that person kind of put me on that oh
we've definitely i would say uh
no you ever heard of like the no jumper
uh people yeah they were
uh early early adopters of what i was
doing like they were like oh my god
there's a rapper named uh
little xanthe and stuff and i think we
made like we made some t-shirts
and they probably sold like 13 of those
t-shirts yeah but
it was the first start and it got me
linked with cole bennett and from there
it just
it went crazy are you are you like you
when you were you were you you were
young you were on the internet
did you you you labeled up kind of quick
or were you like somebody who
went indie for a while uh i was probably
independent for
yeah pretty good time in the beginning
but uh yeah i i
had originally signed a like columbia
records like right after the record went
crazy betrayed uh
it was around the time i you know
columbia all every i feel like i was
going to a label meeting like every week
yeah and uh i landed on columbia but we
had like some differences so
what do you think about in general
people that are making music now are is
it better to just stay indeed oh man we
were just having that conversation
um it's it's a weird time for
music in general like the people that
are like shout out to anybody
who's just blowing up right now like ian
dior kid leroy man they're going crazy
it's just a weird time because you can't
do shows so you know what i mean
it's weird because their spotify numbers
are going crazy but
it's like you can't like take a video of
a sold-out show
and you can't really understand the full
grasp of what somebody's doing right now
because
we're limited to what we can do but it
yeah it's just a weird time so is it is
it
do you think it's good like do the
labels are there good labels that help
you and then
oh yeah the the music industry the
you need like a if you want a certain
thing yeah labels
are definitely the way i'm not against
labels in any way and i'm also not again
against like the independent route
right um because you can make a lot of
money independently yeah but
with what the labels bring to the table
is they bring resources
right resources are probably the single
handling like most important thing
that you need like if you want editorial
playlists on spotify you want to be on
that big spotify playlist
a label will get you that like nothing
right you don't even have to be
a poppin rapper or artist in general you
just have to have the label in it
are you are there people from your life
that are like [ __ ]
like they looked at you and wrote you
off and now you're like kind of
yeah are there people like jesus christ
are there kids that their parents were
like don't hang out with with
zan and now yeah oh yeah that had right
yeah and even
probably some of them yeah well they're
still like
yeah it's definitely people that wrote
me off pretty early on and uh
but you know once you get a little bit
of fame a little bit of money it's like
they all come back but
there's still a pretty good amount of
them that are still like oh [ __ ] this
kid right because like if you come
from like a small town like i did you
don't want to see nobody do
well you know it's kind of [ __ ] up but
it's like i don't know people hate on
like that type of success
yeah i mean i i i think you did it two
in a way that like
you know a lot of people are probably
like you dropped out of school you
started your music like
that's the story of a lot of people a
lot of people don't succeed like that
yeah if it's if you don't want to go the
more conventional route as long as you
know
chase what you want like maybe a dream
or you know like uh steve jobs he
dropped out i think bill gates dropped
out
yeah right yes i think of you steve jobs
and bill gates in the same sense
i usually i i usually group you guys
together bill
took an gates route when did the tats
when did you struggle a while with the
tats oh 18 i got
my mom's name candy tatted on my amazing
and there was no type of success because
now they're pretty common to face
tattoos but back then yeah back then
there was nobody
uh back then it was just a very select
amount of people
that were making soundcloud rap you know
little pete xxx
me and it wasn't like trendy yet and but
i saw it and i was like oh that's
it looks cool i thought it looked cool
it looks cool yeah yeah and then i was
uh i was like what can i get that my
my parents aren't gonna freak out i'll
just get my mom's name in town oh yeah
yeah yeah
that was the first one yeah it was candy
and uh people
they thought i got it because like eye
candy and i was like no i didn't even
think of that yeah it's kind of good
though yeah
um but i got it so she wouldn't be that
match she's still really [ __ ] pissed
yeah i was about to say yeah i guarantee
she was still very
she's still pissed and she's like well
now you have to do something
crazy it almost put you in that box it
did you had the [ __ ]
you had to pop some other way or
something it's hard to walk into a job
interview with
candy on your cheeks yeah they're going
to be good and have a guy go yeah let's
get him involved
yeah he should be the the regional
manager yeah he should be the regional
medic
is it is it wild now when you look back
at that kid who wanted to be a
photographer and you're like
like that kid was just had no idea what
was about to happen no
no [ __ ] idea was about to happen
because like i said
i i did music because i thought it was
cool all my friends did music and then
it actually started working out i was
like oh man this is crazy like this
actually happens
like nobody talks about that like uh
this actually can happen you know people
always think about dreams and stuff and
it's just so far fed it's a dream
yeah you know but for many people it is
far-fetched i mean
you're talented i mean you forget i
appreciate it thank you and i i i
appreciate how inspirational you are
oh thank you man that's not what i do
but the i tell everyone
take that dream and shut now um because
i know a lot of people who are
just they're not i mean they have their
literal dreams where they're waking up
and not
asking you for money or asking you know
their parents
but they're they're you have a [ __ ]
talent you're good you work
you write [ __ ] i mean that's a different
story
it it it be it just becomes yeah it is
work nice
but it just becomes so it just becomes
easier and easier as you get
i guess yeah you're getting better at it
right um but i just i never think about
it like that
are there people you don't keep in your
life now because you're like these are
people who are
not you know good for me they're not
good you know in terms of drugs or in
terms of partying like oh definitely
are there a lot of hangers on and stuff
oh when it when it first started off it
it was crazy everybody wanted to
to come back in my life or even family
like a lot of family members like uh
outer family members like not my mom or
dad right and it was just like
yeah like all the creatures i keep them
away with a stick
yeah right my family all the all the
people i used to go to christmas parties
uh
with they're like oh yo diego yeah come
over and i'm like man i was a black
sheep of the family
right even like before everything so i
was like oh you guys are [ __ ]
[ __ ]
right like now that because i came up
like really poor and stuff so it was
like
so you that's what i want to ask you
about too you grew up
in in uh in redlands california which is
like
uh is is is it's not riverside it's like
uh
right next to riverside right next is
san bernardino and and you grew up you
was you were
poor you didn't have growing up i was i
was do i was all right but then we hit a
time you know
we had a time yeah just hit the [ __ ]
everybody's hitting the time yeah yeah
and what was that like that was horrible
i was uh
my grandma had just passed and and she
was like 99 so she was
[ __ ] old and and then we were you we
were
relying on that that 99 that's like a
mexican legend right
99. it's crazy she was trying to hit 100
but uh movie coco is about her
right what is and uh but we're what's
that thing when uh
uh when you caretaker caretaker checks
we were relying on that to pay the rent
and when she passed away unfortunately
you know we couldn't get those checks
anymore
yeah recipes cram i love you all right
and then uh
we had to we were living in motels like
yeah it got that bad like
uh super eights and stuff yeah yeah man
going back and you know it's in cali
still
yeah and cali like yukaiba right above
and yeah that's [ __ ]
how old were you at that point i
probably had just turned like 18 around
19.
so you're living in like uh you know in
a one-bedroom with your
oh yeah yeah it was so in cockroaches
cockroach and fest it was terrible
and that [ __ ] can get pretty expensive
too of course you pay weekly
it's it's expensive to be poor in
america a lot of people don't realize
that it's a lot of money man to not have
credit or to not have a lot of money and
then you're in and out of these hotels
and it's
[ __ ] it got really bad and but one
thing you're brothers or sisters or just
you
oh just me um well no not just me i have
a half sister and a half brother okay
um i see my sister occasionally but my
brother is actually in prison
oh wow for uh attempted murder okay yeah
but he gets out next year
hey he can try it again and hopefully
this time
i was like listen you can attempt it you
get right out you don't get it right the
first you get right back on the on the
horse that's what i say
yeah now what
was he just mixed up in some bad stuff
right oh yeah he's he's a great
great person just makes the drugs and
yeah he's
i'd like to believe he's changed now so
yeah but you know that
you never know when you get it is he did
was he in jail when you were blown up
yeah oh my god he said that's amazing
watching your little brother
right become a [ __ ] star yeah he
probably pissed him off too because he's
like in there and he's like oh [ __ ] i
want to be out there do you visit him
uh i haven't he's so far away i haven't
seen him in a long time but uh
next year actually yeah when he gets out
i got i got a good situation
yeah sheath underwear i wear it all the
time i wear it in the pool this is a
this is an underwear
that functions as a bathing suit it is
perfect i love it
we all wear it ben wears it dan wears it
everybody i know wears it
i put it on for both of them in the
morning it's part of the job
part of the job description no one's
upset about it hollywood's a fun place
sheath underwear it you it has a little
pouch you tug your [ __ ] in the balls in
the pouch do you use the pouch
yeah yeah sometimes i do yeah no no
ben's got a bigger dick than everyone
else so he gets to use the pouch
sometimes i will use the pouch and
sometimes i won't sometimes it's nice to
tuck it in the pouch
gives you a little bit of like a little
can you give you a happy when you're
walking around
if you're trying to show off uh for the
uh ladies
or gentlemen or dog
you [ __ ] dogs
[Music]
oh
you like dog
buy it you know it's the balls don't get
stuck to your leg the dick goes in the
pouch
everybody is happy use promo code tim
save 20
this is your come to jesus moment do you
believe in the lord or not do you
believe in miracles if so the holy grail
of underwear is upon us sheath is
underwear worn by comedians and ufc
fighters
true warriors on the front line she's
baby
i'm telling you these guys are small
business they love comedy they support a
lot of big podcasts
they support a lot of big podcasts they
support a lot of
people that like to go out and have a
lot of fun and make the world a funnier
place for people they don't never yell
at me about my ads i think
no no no they're fans of the show
they're fans of the show they're fans of
the ads if you really
if you're gonna support somebody it's
killer [ __ ] underwear dude it's
really really good
it's really really really good there are
great gifts for christmas stocking
you'll be the hero
forgiving sheath and they're durable you
could wear them in the pool you could
you could wear them around the house i
mean it's just really a good idea
you can even to be honest with you if
you're in an area where there's not a
lot of people you kind of wear them
jogging
like it's it's they're kind of like
bicycle shorts they're like weirdly
versatile if you're that person you can
kind of just wear them they look like
the band they kind of look like shorts
if you get the black sheath with the red
band they kind of look like shorts
what do the cops gonna stop you
say do you not have pants on
i don't know i'm not saying to go out in
underwear
i don't want to want to do that
but listen they're great underwear
if you want to have sex with a woman or
a man
or a dog if you want to have sex with a
dog
do you understand you know what i'm
talking about there
yeah you dog [ __ ]
what it's comedy folks can everyone
lighten up
just because you're selling a product
doesn't mean it shouldn't be fun
it's great underwear and and people that
have
sex with animals should also be allowed
to wear it
it's true correct correct yes or yes
[Music]
it is the best underwear i love it i
want more of it send me more of a sheath
i'm here in the palm springs heat which
is hotter than the devil's balls
having a cooling underwear with an
amplified size ergonomic pouch that
keeps your boys off your legs is
priceless
this is a great way to start a
conversation with a woman going to date
with go
my balls used to stick to my leg now i
have sheath
underwear can i [ __ ] your dog
how many dates would we have to go on
before we could involve your dog
you ever let me let's get let's pretend
you're on a date
okay okay yeah yeah how are you enjoying
yourself
yeah the salad was sal was okay i mean i
wish the entree had come out already but
what'd you get
um i got the lamb um i heard it's good
here i've never been here before though
what kind of dog damn dog
i have a i have a golden doodle oh yeah
yeah do you have a dog i've had many
dogs
and my my question to you is this
how many dates before we could go back
to your
house and [ __ ] your dog
and then you go i'm wearing sheath and
then she laughs she goes ah
and everyone gets the joke unless she
wants the [ __ ] dog
that's your way out
is there a promo code what are we doing
here use promo code timings
this is the last ad i'm doing for these
people probably i'm kidding i love them
promo code timid save 20 we all the guy
who runs this company said i was a comic
genius today
so what i mean how can he be mad i like
this guy this guy's great yeah
great gifts for christmas stocking
and you will be the hero forgiving
sheath
sheath dot what it's promo code tim and
save 20
promo cod tim you save 20 i'm kidding
about the sex with the dog
anywhere stop canceling the ads to the
show
it's sheath underwear dot com see that
underwear look how good it is it's great
it's great folks get the underwear
please
i'm gonna get wake up to so many calls
tomorrow
i'm kidding
so i'm sick sicko so i'm just jerking
off the thought of it it's like finally
a podcast that recognizes who i
am no all right
magic
that's gonna be you know how we have
ridge well it
the magic spoons one is gonna be magic
[Music]
when i was a kid you know this story
this is a famous story from my life
yes when i was a kid i
went to my friend's house and he had
lucky charms
and i was so jealous because even though
my family was not healthy they refused
to buy me lucky charms now my friend's
parents were drunks at the local bar
who would beat him and and each other
and he had a horrible life he was very
very very hard
um it was a dirty house filthy it
smelled like cats smell like
piss and he'd get knocked around pretty
seriously
by them you know i'm talking clothes
fist
and and as i get older i blame them last
he's because he was a little mouthy
you know what i mean he was a little
mouthy and i'm not saying he was
always in the wrong but
knowing him more and more made me feel
less bad for him
i mean they would just stomp him out
just stomp him out
sometimes we uh knock on the door go can
play and they'd be like hold on and then
you just hear
but were they parents of the year
no but
um and it's a weird thing like the kid
on the block that gets abused but you
agree with the parents
you know what i mean and you picture the
kid getting beaten and you cheer for
yeah you know the kid that's just such a
piece of [ __ ]
you're like yeah i hope you hear just
[Music]
and you're like yeah get him
um buddy but he had the
lucky charms and i remember tasting
those looking
nothing tastes better than a bowl full
of lucky charms
in a house that smells like cat piss
with your friend who has a bloody nose
because he ran his mouth you see
i've been trying to recapture that
feeling
since i was a young man
i've been trying to figure out how
how can i get back the smell of piss and
blood how the smell of dirty
cat dander which is really just the
urine that heart
in the fur and the dander and the
allergies
the filthy clothes it always smelled
like engine oil or
it's grotesque he's dark like think of
the dad from forrest gump who used to
rape jenny
think of him and think of uh
i don't know um a bad mother
leathery dirty smelly
violet people who beat the living [ __ ]
out of their son when they were drunk
but great sugary
cereal he would show up to school
bloodied and battered with a
full tummy of lucky charms
i've been trying to recreate that
someone came up to me and said have you
tried
magic spoon i say maggot spoon
did some somebody came up to me and said
if you tried magic spoon i said you shut
the [ __ ] up
they said you got to do it it's a serial
that fits in
with the keto plan it has zero sugar 11
grams of protein and only three
grams of carbs in each serving there are
four flavors cocoa fruity frosted and
blueberry it tastes amazing honestly too
good to be true
it is keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free
low carb and gmo free
i mean when one of their hands would
start hurting
the other one would just start wailing
them
it was that kind of house one of them
would take a break crack a brew
and then the other one when he would go
to get up to it just
so magic spoon is great cereal
and it helps our show and if you buy it
it helps
you and you can give it to your kids you
don't have to beat them
you could just give the magic spoon you
go to
magicspoon.comtimdillonmagicspoon.com
tim dillon for free
shipping we love them we appreciate that
they support this podcast
because we were all kids and we all want
those sugary cereals
oh yeah you know when you so you're
living in your kaipa
and and and you're in and out of these
motels and stuff
are you are you getting depressed are
you getting like [ __ ] [ __ ] my life
sucks and i don't know what to do crazy
because i wasn't too much depressed
about the situation i was in at the time
but uh i was i was
really just trying to chase my dream i
knew that somebody in the family
had to do something to change the
situation yeah
and but i you know i was just i didn't
know it was gonna happen
so at that time i did have my camera and
i was going out to shows that's how i
met all these guys i've known them for
the whole
majority of my career and i was just
taking pic i was like a super fan
yeah like of these guys and they just
gave me the opportunity
to fly one day out to austin texas and
that's where i got the name lil xan
and uh just yeah it worked out it's
crazy yeah it it's crazy and now
you look you know back on on on that
stuff and it's like maybe that in a
crazy way was good
oh i i've thought about that too like
maybe all that bad [ __ ] that happened
was for the better and it was for the
better because yeah
if i was born [ __ ] rich
right rich parents uh right maybe i
wouldn't have tried so hard to do
something
yeah i know i know you just wouldn't
have been able to make the music that
resonates with people yeah
you took a lot of pain in your music
what kind of rap would you say you do
there's there's a bunch of names for it
oh there's so many names i don't like to
label it but right
people probably call it like cloud rap
mumble rap
right just a whole like little
soundcloud kind of era soundcloud kind
of era yeah but you talk about a lot of
pain addiction oh emo yeah [ __ ] like
that sad
yes like sad sad rap sad rap emo rap
that's definitely what a lot of us fall
into
i love that we used that song slingshot
oh you were telling me yeah we use that
pull up that video where at the end of
the video we use that slingshot
slingshot was the song that we always
used
and you never suit us we appreciate that
we love that so i listen to that song
before i go on stage a lot yeah it's a
good pump
up the the other one betrayed it
afterwards i kill myself but
the slingshot one gets me yeah that
one's a little different
i started listening i'm like yeah i've
been [ __ ] over my life
where did you do that video by the way
that's it of course right forest falls
it's like
yeah like an hour it's on the way here
yeah but it's a waterfall at the end
just pulled that i'd like to end the
last few seconds of this video
but we used to and then when i would do
tour date announcements we would do this
[ __ ]
it looks yeah yeah looks like
i love that we love we love that video
yeah i love that it's my ass crack and
then that song
we loved it yeah but yeah man it's like
what do you
what do you like what do you think of
l.a in hollywood is it is it
or do you love it are you like is this
it's crazy are you a guy that goes out
to these places like
whether it's boa steakhouse or any of
these guys saddle ranch are you one of
these
like because you would get you know when
you walk in everybody turns their head
everybody knows who you are
when i walk in it's the same thing
people people often are like oh amy
schumer's here
and and i appreciate that what um what
do you
think about like the l.a training spot
trendy [ __ ] like
uh are you into that [ __ ] is it fun to
you or you like ah it's [ __ ] annoying
i mean i love going to good restaurants
and having good you know good food
your boy diablo goes to boa all the time
goes inside let's see
i see him all the time he just [ __ ]
loves steak or whatever
all the time uh i wouldn't say i'm super
into
the trendiness of like you eat food are
you like an eater yeah
yeah oh this year especially during the
pandemic i just that's all i do is
that's how i discovered saddle and stuff
because you like taco bell i love taco
bell yeah and del taco
and delta now interesting now yeah this
is the way i think of both of them i
think del taco might have actually
better food but i think
taco bell might have better food no i
think del taco doesn't matter
yeah but i think taco bell has more
transcendent moments
and they're just better yeah and like
branding and it's just
those iconic kind of flavors you could
tell that they're better at branding
it's a
it's definitely a bigger chain than you
had an incident at taco bell do you
remember what happened what happened to
talk about didn't you throw
you had like a fit or something i've had
many by the way
no no i probably did i'm not i've had
many incidents and if i would if
i had near your level of notoriety at
your age i would be in jail
but oh the yeah the the food court what
happened to the food court do you
remember
okay i was i had i was with this girl
she's she was beautiful
and of course so you're taking her to
the nice place i'm taking her to a food
court where you should take a beautiful
girl too of course
and uh it's that's a crazy story uh some
some dude who worked at the the food
court i got a wetsuit
i don't even know he's all he's all
dressed up in his uniform
and he comes up and at this time
everybody's trying to take a picture at
the mall
um he he's like yo can i can i take a
picture and i'm like yeah you know i'm
cool with that
and he's like no not of you i want a
picture with your girl yeah that's
[ __ ] up
yeah i know that's [ __ ] up and i it's
ridiculous yeah i was like what the [ __ ]
like it took me a minute to practice
like no get the [ __ ] out of here go back
he's literally in like a little wetzel
pretzel like yeah yeah yeah yeah little
apron
and then yeah i couldn't i couldn't let
that is that him
is that the wetzel though yeah i
couldn't let i couldn't let him go out
like that
i couldn't let myself go out like that
yeah so so he went back to his little
stand after a little altercation
i had a slushie in my hand right so and
i've done this many times in life i
don't know why i don't know why i always
have a slushie in my hand
and so i walked over there and just
chucked that up hit him perfectly and
perfectly he jumped up on the table and
at that time my security is like already
blocking everything
right that was funny yeah who does that
though it's
[ __ ] up to do like props you're taking
a girl out on a date
yeah the food court the food and you
expect people to be classy he came up to
me and like
ten of my friends and like had the balls
to just say that you roll deep you
always have an entourage oh yeah i like
that
yeah just there's people as you can see
on the internet i just have ben i always
take ben
i would say guys better looking to me
everything right there and then
he gets in first and then i'm screaming
and i'm back in the livestream
i'm i'm led into a service entrance yeah
um yeah but that's crazy but you get you
can and what happened with the hot
cheetos because
oh that was people always ask me if that
was really fake now because that was as
real as it is
i think i made a joke i think i was on
stage at the comedy store and i was like
little sam said he went to the hospital
it was a hot cheetos
yeah it wasn't an iron what happened was
i ate a i had a couple bags and i've
looked this up
this could just happen this happens it's
gonna happen i ate a couple bags and i
started puking and
there was a little a little bit of blood
in there and i was like well maybe
that's just the hot
no blood looks like a certain way yeah
and i freaked out a little bit went to
the hospital no big deal
like just stop eating [ __ ] cheetos
it's just because of your your
background
people are probably skeptical yeah when
i say i'm on the keto diet
and i go to dairy queen and i say i
thought they were giving covet tests
there and i just end up with a blizzard
by mistakes yeah
it feels like when you say hot cheetos a
lot of people think yeah and just
all the media outlets picked it up and
thought it was i don't even know if i
said
overdose in the video but there's he
overdosed on some hot cheetos
and i was like [ __ ] just wrong with
it they just really are do you hate them
do you hate the media are you like
oh no [ __ ] these people there's there's
certain outlets
it's how they make their money right
yeah it's certain i can't hate on
anybody just doing what they do to make
money you know
right i like tmz and i like uh a lot of
the media outlets
some more favorable than others but yeah
have you ever had people reach out to
you that really like your music that
are that you would be shocked or
surprised like is there anybody there's
so many people
yeah i think it's always shocking right
yeah um
who would you say you probably have a
certain demo a fan right yeah it's like
when you were like i think you're funny
i was like that's
really awesome and so very surprising
yeah but that was great not super
surprising i think it's not surprising
it's not that surprising
but it do you ever have somebody come up
to you like
just a 75 year old woman he's like oh
there's always old there's
i love you it's always uh old women
old women where i go it's like it's it's
[ __ ] weird i have meet and greets and
maybe it's just like the moms of
daughters yeah that's awesome
yeah they're always it's it blows my
mind because uh they'll travel like
14 hours in a car to come and see me
like at a spot
in vegas we had that happen i was like
oh you guys i love it i love it uh it's
just
it blows my mind and then the the the
the band corn right
yeah corn uh they invited us me and my
friend out to uh it's awesome
a show and i was like surprised it's
dope corn is is [ __ ] dope
but marilyn manson was there it was
crazy it was crazy
because you do kind of straddle that
thing where it's like it's kind of like
you rap but you're also like like in the
alternative like
alternative people like you and rockers
would like you and stuff like which is
so cool because i grew up on you know
marilyn manson and coin so it's just
like that's what blows my mind away it's
like wow like this is
art you think hollywood's a lot of fake
friends a lot of people that are out of
shape i think hollywood's a lot of fake
people in general right you know what i
mean you can't escape that
you go there's real people everywhere
but it more or less yeah hollywood
what do you think about the country
right now the election and all the
craziness going on
are you worried are you scared of covid
or you i think i was really scared of
covid when we didn't know
don't get me wrong it's it's horrible
you know it's right it's a horrible it
is a scary [ __ ] thing
but i was more scared when it was like
unknown you know what i mean when people
when it was just like a little virus
coming out of wuhan and people didn't
know
it's it's [ __ ] scary uh i don't know
anybody personally that's passed away
but i know a lot of people that do know
people that have passed away yeah
and you know i try to be safe around
like my family my mom's
my mom's like 62. so i always wear a
mask when i go over there and try to
social distance but i think the country
this is a horrible year
it's a tough year man the weird [ __ ]
it's one for
the history books like yeah it certainly
is what do you think is to do who do you
think will win the election you know
oh man i i think it's a crazy election
uh
oh that's always a hard topic um
i don't think your fans are huge trump
people i'm not i'm not i'm not a big
trump
uh sounds like i gotta be very careful
there's a lot of orange county boat guys
that love what i do i would say i grew
up i want to offend them i
grew up uh very blue you know of course
um
i would say i'm more like in the
independent i like to just think of
you know just whatever i yeah that's
what i consider myself independent i'm
independent i'm all over the place
yeah i i think trump winning again would
be no good
because i think it'd be bad just because
we're we're at we need
some something's got to change yeah
we're just headed towards a [ __ ]
construction we're heading towards like
we're heading towards destruction
i just don't know what el i mean it's
just but i mean he might win again if he
wins again it is what it is i wake up do
what i do i don't care
it's it's just it's it's a crazy time
and especially this this election they
said it's gonna be like the craziest
election that we've ever had too
yeah it's just nobody knows are you a
conspiracy dude at all
when it's like a good conspiracy it's
not like some [ __ ] weird fart
out there but yeah like good
conspiracies there's a lot of rap dudes
independent raptors that love the
conspiracies yeah a lot of fun
what's your favorite conspiracy uh so
one of my favorites currently
is that jfk jr who's a john f kennedy's
son
uh uh they said he's not dead that he's
been kept alive and he's going to
replace
mike pence as donald trump jr's donald
trump's running mate
that's what that thing is yeah there's
an on time okay just come back in the
fourth of july that's [ __ ]
that's just fun i like that and then
he's gonna come back princess diana and
a bunch of
i like when people come back that's a
fun one it's a good [ __ ] kisses they
come back for me we were just talking
about
the princess diana one that's a i
believe in i believe that she was killed
you know i believe she was probably
killed
she was definitely good we should just
probably kill two you she's dating this
guy dodie on fiance she's gonna marry
him
maybe the royal family didn't like that
very strange stuff like that yeah
and then like the i've seen everything
yeah i've seen that's [ __ ] [ __ ] up
yeah what do you think have you ever
been around people hollywood were you
like that they're shady
i don't want to be around them all the
time like yeah all the time like uh
people want something if you if you can
give if you can
benefit somebody else they want it you
know and i like it
and like unfortunately i can benefit a
lot of people in some ways so they
you just gotta it's it's about like
finding who's real
and who's not but that it's a weird
blurred line right there
do you look at young artists and i want
to help that person i think that person
is great
of course if i if i like the music if
just or even if i just like them as a
person and i can have them
you know develop their sound yeah i'm
into that that's great do you take them
on the road or how do you do it
yeah we've uh we've taken people on
tours like shout out this this
girl artist named fem um super super
cool we took her on tour she's killing
it now
um on her own uh who else are we like
taking we're taking like
steve steve my homie steve but it's just
crazy because like
we've been around like other successful
people before they were successful
right like like little mosey shout out
to little mosey he's killing it right
now doing so good
um we were i think we might have been
one of the first people to like how many
and there's this serious question how
many lils are there there's like a lot
it's like a huge thing now it's a little
most yeah i think it's always been
yeah it's always been a thing it's
probably bigger now than it is
and that was a dude that you knew back
before he was yeah this was like
seattle yeah seattle like like three
four
two three years ago and now he's just
killing it and i'm not saying we
did anything you know for his like
success i'm just saying we've just been
around like i was around
xxx centauri and i stayed in airbnb i
picked him up from the airport
uh way back in the day and it was just
so cool insanely talented dude
oh man yeah yeah so [ __ ] talented him
in ski mask
and it just i think there's something
about i think all
artists like if you surround yourself
i was sometimes like like i was around
xxx
when they were just blowing up and i
wasn't [ __ ] you know what i mean right
but i think that
rubs off on people a little bit yeah you
know what i'm going to be around people
that are doing what if you surround
yourself with like
successful talented good people
i think that's where everybody comes
from you know what i mean right and
i was lucky enough to be to surround
myself what separates those dudes for
there's a lot of guys that get into that
try to do it what separates those guys
do you think is it is it work ethic is
it just
like from uh unsuccessful yeah from the
people that judge don't figure out a way
to put it together
there's something this might sound crazy
but i think there's something just
really divine
about it again speaking about x
there was just something insanely cool
he just gave off this energy that i've
never even felt like before
uh same with like juice world like when
i was around juice world a couple of
times it just gave off this
great divine energy that you know you
know they're gonna be
superstars and just kill it and i feel
like
it sucks that their their lives you know
were taken so early
there's just something so divine about
them as people
so that people yeah yeah little peep and
all those
mac miller too it's not like oh mac yeah
and that that'll did you know mac well
uh we were i would say we were friends
maybe more queens as friends but we had
we had uh hung out uh
a few times yeah um like public settings
and stuff
he was so cool man he was he's one of my
favorite artists yeah
do you think that like
addiction for some for whatever reason
like a lot of people that are
addicts or have that mentality end up
being being
great artists um unfortunately i think
it seems to always kind of steer that
way where
i do think that drugs can provide you
not like a specific drug
just drugs in general can provide you
with like a different look on life
it could help the music it could hurt
the music
but like i said you could you could find
that inspiration sober
i just think a lot of people sometimes
get in this habit of thinking that they
can't be creative without
drugs or some sort of stimulant right
and that's that's where people
is it tough to date girls now that
you're successful when you don't know
who's gonna
[ __ ] oh yeah he likes you for who
i've definitely dated some women that
were just in it for cloud or money or
whatever
but uh i'm with the girl right now that
i love her
yeah i'm in love like i've never been in
love like right before is that good for
creativity oh yeah you just make a bunch
of love songs
but you know what else is good for
creativity it's going through getting
less yeah
i love your life yeah the cops go having
to love yourself
a real like with that real love yeah
like oj and nicole simpson has
so such a real l.a love their glove love
glove
just you know really results in
something you know
are you like what's the next step what
are you trying to do next
do you ever see yourself as like you
know you're a funny guy you're on social
media a lot
you ever see yourself getting into other
[ __ ] you're like i love music
i want to do uh would you ever do a tv
show would you ever do
uh more content on youtube would you
ever do anything like that
that's that's the future of uh xanarchy
my brand
yeah i want to take this i just want to
brand it by the way zan has acquired
this show
xanarchy has just bought the tim dillon
show
very she was a pack of cigarettes he
bought it it was very cheap and i signed
it was very cheap
and uh and now we're that's our brand
yeah i would love to do like uh
something like this like a podcast like
obviously podcasts are the new
like cool thing and stuff yeah but i've
always thought they were just
you know you could learn more about the
person yeah that's what i
i really [ __ ] with is i want more people
to think of me in like a less
ignorant kind of way because i know a
lot of people look at me and they
instantly just write me off because
they're like oh he's stupid look at him
like
i think a lot of people are like he's
just wild yeah like they see you
and they hear some of the stories and
they're like he's just like media
definitely it doesn't help that
the media doesn't help and they're just
like you're a whirling dervish yeah
they're like this this guy's off
office [ __ ] uh yeah and i i don't
disagree because you're also growing up
yeah you're [ __ ] what 24 25 i just
turned 24 yeah dude you're a young
[ __ ] kid
still and i mean now you're growing up
on drugs though the reason i had all
these like these wild incidents
i can almost guarantee you eighty
percent of it is because i was
[ __ ] high off my mind obviously let
me tell you xanax
is a hell of a [ __ ] jug what is i
never got into it i was coke i was i
love smoking weed
i like percocet you know what i mean
yeah i'm a little i'm a little classy
uh polo shirt thank you uh zanny's or
zany bars were like i don't know people
were getting into it we became trendy
recently
become trendy recently i sobered up
about ten years ago
i love the percocet you know i took an
80 milligram oxy once
and not once but 70 or 80 times
but i remember me and my friend were
just we're laying we
he was on a couch i was on a couch you
like staring at yourself we're just
scratching it was too much for me
oh yeah too much it can be overwhelming
same with the zen so what is this any
bars they do what do they do they just
because they know their anti-anxiety
they numb you out
they give you like the craziest uh
euphoria
this false con like sense of false
conflict interesting
false confidence like it will make you
think that you
are like the [ __ ] if you are and uh
a lot of these rappers i don't i don't
know what the xanax scene is like in rap
but i know when i first came on the
scene
i was a little zam because it was
[ __ ] everywhere right uh
and it just gave you this crazy sense of
like you could do your invincible you
could do this you could do that
and that that can work in your favor
sometimes but people would just start
thinking you're
[ __ ] obnoxious all the time like i
can't tell you i mean people i've been
around like oh god
what about there's all kinds of other
sit down there's like lean and there's
all kinds of
homemade cakes what is that for people
that don't know what that is lean is a
cough syrup different brands
have different types like guac hard and
activist is
discontinued but it's been lean's been
around for a minute
and it just falls into the rap drug
category if there's like a rap starter
pack you'd be like percocet
zan's lean lean okay face that's like a
tough face that dude
face tattoos yeah to get started skinny
jeans reaper just to get started when
you said the thing about tupac would you
think that was the most
were you mischaracterized was that the
most mischaracterized thing oh that was
definitely the most
started like a huge thing where you were
just like i didn't realize what it would
be
and i was i was again high off my mind i
was sleepy i was pissed i didn't want to
be there
i was almost just i was really mad at
the interviewer before anything
i just didn't want to be there so i was
kind of in like a [ __ ] shitty mood
yeah uh i i don't i don't dislike to
talk in any way
you just said you you see he's a [ __ ]
legend right and you said it was like
boring or something quick and you were
kind of like it was like i was trying to
write off every question so quick
because it was just
like [ __ ] it if you watch that interview
you can see me i'm just in the chair
like
right rocking back i'm like i don't want
to be there i didn't think anything of
it nobody thought anything of it but
yeah i think that was have you ever had
beefs with bigger rappers and are they
are they squashed which is i believe the
terminology you google yeah
squash thank you i i don't have anything
against anybody
and i know that's crazy for probably
people to hear because i've been
involved in a lot of stuff like
i remember when yeah the tupac stuff ti
was on twitter
talking you know [ __ ] and waka flocka
was trying to ban me from hip hop and i
was just like
i was like i i get where they're coming
from but you're a kid you're a young kid
yeah i was i was you understand this
that guy's a you know there's a god and
yeah he is a guy
thing and he didn't mean it i did not
mean that and
but it was a catalyst for hay and a lot
of people you know tried to just like
blackball me and do this
and i just it's just wild because i
as in like uh the most adult i've
probably ever been in my life
at this point sober i'd have nothing
against anybody
you know and i see where they're coming
from right i was a little ignorant kid
saying some stupid [ __ ] so but i just
want everybody to know i'm cool with
everybody
no days wasted dhmd talks
okay i'll tell you right now folks
i'm very excited about this new product
it is the vitamin
for people who like to enjoy their
drinks and my audience likes ever
cocktail let's be honest
tens of thousands of people are using
dhm detox as their drinking body enjoy
your drinks
and forget hangovers feeling like
garbage their company is built on the
words no days wasted
you know when i was a young guy i used
to be able to drink all night
wake up and be a lifeguard it's true i
was a lifeguard
i didn't save anyone one time a kid
actually the owner of the thing came
over to us and he's like they're saying
the mother saved them because you two
are out of it and i'm like
whatever that's a better system anyway
strong families helping each other
but i was a pool lifeguard i didn't
really get in the you know i didn't have
to save anyone
um but i always felt sharp but as you
get older
it's harder to feel sharp after you've
had a night out on the town
and you need something you don't want to
use pharmaceuticals you don't want to
use things that aren't natural
dhm detox is made up of natural
ingredients antioxidants and vitamins it
takes two capsules
after your first couple of drinks and it
goes to work just take two after the
first couple of drinks
they come in convenient packets that are
easy to share with friends and family
while you're celebrating or socializing
dhm detox is a risk-free purchase so if
you aren't satisfied after taking the
product
they'll give you your money back it's a
no-brainer give it a shot these really
work a lot of my friends are using them
my friends love to party but they got to
be up early to do their jobs
you get 20 off your first order and free
shipping in the us
just head over to knowdayswasted.co
no days wasted dot co slash tim
promo code tim at checkout no days
wasted dot
co slash tim promo code tim at checkout
this is a great way to ensure that
you're not gonna have a hangover
you take two of them you go out to
dinner you have a couple of drinks you
go
dancing you wake up you are as
productive as ever and you feel
great and they do it all naturally it
helps break down all the toxins in your
body
and it helps boost your body's natural
response to alcohol
so it breaks it down quicker and you're
ready to go the next day i'm telling you
this is a great idea to take no days
wasted dot
c-o-t-i-m
keeps guys i
people are getting blotchy people losing
their hair my opener's losing it a
little bit not that much he's still [ __ ]
him please he's great
um but the reality is uh so much of your
identity is wrapped up in your hair
from how it feels after getting a fresh
cut to the way it's perfectly styled
before going out did you know two out of
three guys will experience some form of
male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss is to
do something about it while you still
have hair left get treated from home
you just have to go to the doctor's
office for your hair loss prescription
now thanks to keeps
you can visit a doctor online and get
hair loss medication delivered right to
your home
here's the reality keeps is giving
generic versions of the only two fda
approved hair loss products out there
keeps is the thing it helps you keep
your hair it prevents you from losing
your hair
okay it takes four to six months to see
results so if you act fast and start now
you're going to stop losing your hair it
is important it is cheaper it is way
cheaper
than doing the fda uh approved hair loss
products out there this is the same
ingredients they work perfectly
this has all the great reviews uh has
more five star reviews on amazon than
any of its competitors
there's over a hundred thousand men
trust keeps this is a great product
if you're even losing your hair a little
bit or you're you're whatever you're
gonna
love keeps you're gonna need keeps i'm
telling you right now you know keebs.com
tim dillon keeps.com tim dillon it is
k-e-e-p-s dot com can we get this for my
opener
yeah we'll get it for dan it's good to
just do because you know my hair is i
mean it's luscious
but some people you know they're losing
their hair yeah
i get it i get it but what we have to do
is we have to focus on
keeping what you got save what you got
don't you don't need wigs or toupees or
that fake hair or spraying bald spots or
any of the horror
no you know you don't need those uh
surgical implants and the nightmares
i'm telling you right now the reality is
just keep what you got right now
act fast act fast
keeps dot com slash tim dillon k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash tim dillon it's a great
way to support the show
and quite frankly it is one of the best
products for for
a male a vital male that wants to have
hair even though testosterone kind of i
think
you go bald if you have a lot of
testosterone but whatever the point is
no like women don't care try to explain
that to a woman
it's actually because i have more
testosterone away
get the hair get the keeps keep your
hair
don't get the hair keep your hair
keeps.com slash tim dillon
how about this take a picture of your
head now and in four months
prove to me prove to me
that you got keeps
get the keeps and uh well i don't know
we'll figure out what we do at that
point for you but
i don't know what we're gonna do for you
what should we do for them
uh instagram shout out maybe
yeah maybe you get that on the stories
not the not the feed you don't get the
feed
you get the stories how about a facebook
shout out okay we go to the book
maybe you don't deserve the gram if you
buy all the products you get the gram
if you buy all the products i'll promote
your business on my instagram if you can
prove to me you bought all of our
products
i will put your business in my instagram
story is that allowed
i think so yeah yeah as long as that's
some [ __ ] crazy
it can't be like an illegal business it
can't be illegal
can't be what's your name from prison
call me below up all of it i got kicked
and i got magic spoon and what i wanted
to do i'm advertising a party
that i'm having on a yacht because we've
got to be on boats now we've got to keep
it moving
chislet jizz lane where's she by the way
what happened to that keebs.com dylan
goodbye
do you do you when you in terms of
sobriety how are you
managing that are you going to meetings
you talking to friends and family crazy
uh yeah because i how long are you sober
now i've been sober since
may 22nd may 22nd okay great
and uh it i didn't go to rehab i didn't
was there an event where you were just
like i'm not the seizures i had uh
did we talk about that on here and yeah
you should only get like five seizures
yeah
i had five seizures in one day and i was
trying to just quit everything cold
turkey and they
the doctors were like you we you can't
do that like that's bad
you could die but i you know i just
wanted to quit it cold turkey
and sean excuse me i'm talking a little
zan
lose my number i hate my family
take this out jesus christ
my [ __ ] family he's opening up about
seizures and i got these idiots
who want free tickets so
you have five i need some free tickets
uh you get you get all the free things
you want yes and dan we're going to
tampa dan's requesting about 45 free
tickets
for everyone he knows that [ __ ] tampa
to come here how am i going to pick
anybody
all the girls and stuff yeah all this
hoes the hollywood i was going to say
that [ __ ] yeah
if you're on youtube instagram facebook
snapchat let's go
um linkedin yeah we just had like a few
seizures in one day
crazy wish he's just [ __ ] crazy dude
like you don't even remember anything
you just what is it because i've never
had one and i've seen people have it
it's one of the most disturbing things
to watch
yeah oh my god yeah my girl at the time
saw it and
and she just cries every time like i
talk about it and i'm like [ __ ] i must
look
crazy uh it's just like you're there one
minute you kind of start hallucinating a
little bit but you don't realize you're
hallucinating
and you think like you're asleep and
then you just like wake up and you're
[ __ ] scared
you don't even feel it happening no like
you don't you just wake up like you just
blacked out wake up
and but you're terribly scared you just
don't know like you're having trouble
breathing
anxiety is going crazy i remember when i
woke up from it i was like screaming
like
like like you know like [ __ ] bloody
murders i don't know what i was
screaming but
right and all my family's around me just
looking at me like what the hell is up
with you so then it was like we got over
the hospital yeah we went to the
hospital
you know they got to run uh the cat
scans and stuff
thank god i was fine but i knew at that
point that i really just had to
stay sober and it was the seizure caused
by the drugs
it was caused from uh xanax withdrawal
not even perkins and not not even
persons just straight
xanax withdrawal jesus christ that
that's how you know that drug is
is wild so your but your brain needs it
yeah function
yeah you serotonin receptors so the
doctors were like you can't cold turkey
this yeah and at that point i'd already
had the seizures and i was just really
they put me on anti-seize medication so
i was just like
maybe this you know will prevent
seizures i could just
quit and everybody was telling me go to
rehab cause i needed professional help
and i'm so like you know i'm just like i
could do this and right
it was hard it was really hard i
couldn't sleep i couldn't eat
i lost a lot of weight but a month after
i
came out you know stronger than i've
ever been yeah and you're
and you're [ __ ] you're doing good now
and this is yeah this is the future the
future for you is just
it's clean yes i i i just want to help
other people
you know i think i sent you a message on
twitter i was just like gotta stay sober
oh yeah i just said i met cause i was
just like this kid talented dude and i
didn't know you but i was just like this
guy's
you see young people sometimes and like
i remember being what being an addict is
like
and it's horrible and i remember like
you know also being being somebody who
wants to create [ __ ] and make [ __ ] and
like how all those worlds fuse together
in a very [ __ ] negative way oh yeah
absolutely it's also horrible for you
know it's not just horrible for you it's
horrible for everybody involved
everybody family yeah everybody around
you uh your girl
yeah everybody everybody's worried
they're just thinking oh one day he's
not going to wake up
yeah and that's just you know this is
the scariest thing ever are you excited
about when quarantine ends you could
kind of come off
to come out of quarantine you come
straight live shows again yeah
you missed that adrenaline and getting
on stage there's no better feeling than
being on stage performing for
like you know sold-out show it's like
it's the best feeling
the adrenaline is is pumping
it's just amazing that people like that
you can do something where
you know thousands of people will come
out just to see you like i'm so grateful
for that
yeah there's it's a blessing it's
amazing to me because i'm going out you
know
and and these people coming out in a
pandemic and it's like i saw that [ __ ]
it yeah
it was packed i mean we're selling that
all over the people are just really
happy to be out and we're just having
fun because
people need to laugh right now yeah
that's so important right now
that's it's is the comedy uh store in uh
hollywood open yet it's not open yet not
yet we're hoping we don't know
you know i think it's just going to be
we're going to be down for the winter
i think spring is going to be spring i
think that's just what's going to happen
i think we just kind of head through the
holidays and that's going to happen
everything this is going to become like
a new norm i hope not but i i do think
there's a possibility of that
i i just think that people want freedom
too much in the sense that they
they don't want real freedom but they
want to go out yeah so i don't
find any excuse to go out yeah i i do
think that come spring
after we've made it through maybe a
second wave of this i think people are
just going to say to themselves like
[ __ ] it
i want to be they're going to get tired
of it they're going to get tired they're
already getting they're already getting
people already getting tired people
getting tired of this [ __ ] people like
[ __ ] it if i'm going to die i'm going to
die but i just can't sit in my room
anymore because
yeah and i also another thing about this
pandemic is like
when i was in the hospital for the
seizures it was like the beginning of it
kind of
and you can't have guests you know what
i mean like in
right around so this is a horrible time
to to just
die yeah you gotta die horrible you
gotta die alone in the hospital you
can't have loved ones around you
it's a horrible time to have a kid you
know it's crazy my friend
my friend just had a kid it's so hard
nobody could be in the delivery room
wow that is so crazy and then and and
if you're in a hospital dying now you
cannot see your family at all
like which to me sounds oh doesn't it
yeah but
i do understand that many people have a
problem with that
um it is tough man when you see these
people facetime you it's [ __ ]
horrible
and that's why i do comedy because i try
to laugh at horrible [ __ ] because i
don't know what else to do with it yeah
i think you try to make music
and that's how you deal with it yeah
that's how we deal with how [ __ ] up
the world is but yeah the comedy
that's so people need that right people
need that man i just
you know i i i don't know what else to
do i look at this world and i it's so
[ __ ] up
and there's so much injustice and i
think that like people could should go
out and you know make whatever change
they can make but you know also in your
own life like treat people well and
everything which i tried
yeah what's that saying treat people how
you want to be treated
yeah i i like being treated poorly so
that's a horrible
quote for me i truly enjoy being treated
very like when i go to a restaurant they
treat me like [ __ ] i'm like yeah i like
that
i like to know where i'm at yeah uh like
i went to nobu the other day and they
were just saying i have a reservation
like what you know i was just like oh
wait sushi in my [ __ ]
car they're like we have a table in four
and a half hours
they didn't know they said four and a
half hours it was some crazy wait time i
was just like just put it in a [ __ ]
box
and just send me almost of course tick
tocker is like 15 year olds being shot
at the tables they're like hello
what you said about salad ranch and uh
it's just a bunch of tick tockers eating
that chicken fingers yeah it's pretty
funny i mean it's
it's silly it's it's it's crazy i come
from new york which is a real city
and i mean i i you know with all due
respect to everyone here
uh ella i love la but la's a little
ridiculous but i think that's what makes
la fun
yeah that's what gives la it's charms
that it's a little wacky la's very
ridiculous it's a little wacky to see
paparazzi
climbing over hedges to interview a
child and then they're interviewing a
child and then the child says what a
child would say they'll be like
uh addison what what's going on and some
girl be like i just got a car
and they're like yeah good you and i'm
like this girl's just having a normal
17 year old experience yeah and you're
chasing them through the streets
do you deal with a lot of paparazzi do
you deal with people just uh trying to
find you and
yeah when we go out it's if they're
there they definitely come ask some
questions
but i do agree it is it is wild that uh
because i'm
i i i appreciate what tick-tock is you
know sure yeah it takes a lot of [ __ ]
it's good for music and if you can make
money off tick-tock and you can get it
notoriety that's that's epic i love it i
love that for you
i'm not as tapped in i do do tick tock i
don't dance on tick tock
right but i try to make you jump around
on stage though yeah that's like the
same thing just translate that uh yeah
but i like uh i'm not really tapped into
i'm trying to get more tapped into the
tick tock community i i we make tick
tocks and
but they're just funny they're funny you
know what i mean they're random funny
they're not like the dances
but i want i'm not that tapped in so
when they ask like in the paparazzi like
hollywood fix or something
i always watch those videos and it's
like they're asking some crazy what's
happening in the tick tock world of
beef drama and i'm i'm so i'm getting
older
you're getting older yeah like that's
getting older because it's definitely a
young person it's like a really good
person
and so so you're somebody who you're
actually creating a thing
so a lot of people on tick tock are it's
a very transient
style of fame where they're a lot of
those guys the smart ones are now doing
f finance advice podcasts like bryce
hall and these guys and they're like
smart
they're like smart guys because they
realize you're like
okay i'm not gonna dance forever but i'm
gonna i'm gonna become like an angel
investor and try to it's evolving
i mean they're evolving into like that
thing but those guys aren't artists
you know what i mean that's a different
thing i think
i don't think they would say they're
artists i don't think somebody wants
this i don't think somebody with their
shirt off on tick tock twitch just
dancing yeah would say
those videos maybe they're so
uncomfortable the little tick tock e
boys
i yeah i would there's not art that's
not making a song
that's not writing a book it's kind of i
mean it can't be art if that's art we're
in trouble
i don't hate it i'm like good and make
your money yeah make your money what
those people tell you what mac miller
did that's very different
very different and i think they know
that the smart tick talkers know that
which is why they're like here's an
energy drink like they get oh like the
bang energy
yeah they get it i think they all have
invest and believe me
i love tick tockers i'm not on here i i
love tick tock me too
make that clear you know what i mean but
and i respect it
it's it's just it's just it's different
like uh like you said the energy drinks
i always see the bang
energy well it's just it's it's it's
it's it's branding and marketing it's
smart
they all have investors right that's
crazy that's the craziest [ __ ]
you you you didn't get famous for being
famous you got famous because you were a
musician you're a rapper
yeah and you made music yeah and you
were in that scene but i think
that's how it started off but i think
what happened was yeah the the little
zen persona
became huge just its own thing online
yeah you know like
i love making music and i have a lot of
fans that love me for my music
but i feel like a lot of people just
joined in and it was just like i just
want to see what the [ __ ] a little dan
does now have you do you see kids that
emulate you like you ever go out and see
a little or zan
little or zan that should be a rapper
if i'm little or something yeah shout
out there's actually a dope audience
named emotional zam
emotional yeah he's that and you you're
cool with that no
lawsuits yeah emotionally right if you
can make if you can make it work with
the name like that's
epic so yeah what what are you yeah
emotionally looks crazy oh my god
this guy's no joke do you know him oh
we've talked before
just like a little uh we got zan in our
name
with zan in the name can never have a
normal appearance like it's got to be
wild
it's got to be out there yeah that's
crazy look at that
shout out emotional zam oh he's killing
it i love that
i love that so much that's great
emotional zan holding a
a gun very good what what
everyone holds all of this and family
loves the web yeah we all get together
and talk we're in a group chat
all the time i love that what are you
what's the uh what what if you could
have one if you could do one thing
in terms of a goal is that you want to
put out an album that's the killer most
killer thing do you
what what's the one thing we're doing
world tour like yeah we're definitely
working on
the second album um yeah just trying to
find is it harder a second album
it's it's a little i think making an
album in general is a little tricky
because yeah you just
music's always evolving so you guys are
trying to get
ahead of it so you can find out what the
next this is the next like what like
what mgk michigan kelly's doing yeah he
nailed it he's evolved yeah he's
evolving from smart
crap to the the pub good it's good
valentine's day good songs
oh it's so good all this so we're just
listening to his album it's it's it's
it's amazing that he the way he
transitioned and he just had a number
one album
doing that pop punk stuff which proves
like where music's going they like that
alternative rock there's no borders
anymore like
you can just you can do whatever like
i'm having a conversation with you
that's crazy you're crossing the board
this is a crazy thing yeah machine gun
kelly can do alternative stuff
you can do whatever you want everybody
can do donald trump can be the president
i mean it's really
wild wow it's wild i mean there's no
limits to anything
yeah so if anybody's ever telling you
like you can't do that well
you can [ __ ] do it yeah you know
there's there's
nothing you can't do at this point 2020
proved that 2020 proves it i'm excited
for 2021.
hopefully it's worse
[Laughter]
yeah all right so now so you're so we're
we're excited that you're so it's the
new sober zan
this is the first time no more no more
now if so if you ever throw a fit now
taco bell you're doing it sober i do it
sober
yeah i get i get angry sober and you can
too at this point if i yeah if i throw a
fit somewhere
you don't have to be on drugs what is
your order at taco bell or del taco just
had it
taco ah just uh we used to call it the
stoner burrito but they used to get
pissed it's just the burrito with the
the fries in it
oh yeah california burrito was that it's
not called the stone arena this was the
conversation
yeah yeah they used to order it and be
like yo can we get this stone and
burrito they're like we don't know what
that is
yeah he's ordered the right sounds like
can i have the oxy guacamole
can you just use the menu yeah can you
use the menu
please can i get the the zen oh man look
at this
yeah that's what he's the cause you're
just hanging out of a g wagon yeah
at that time i was in a beat-up nissan
versa now you're in the g
now i'm in the g right where it's tight
inside a little bit yeah you know
they don't i wish like i knew more about
the car before i got it because right
it's like a boat you know it's yeah it's
it's it drives itself like
you want to go left it goes [ __ ]
right it's it's right i love it
but it is you know when you make money
and you're making money now what what
are the things
are you a clothes guy you like cars
what's the thing where you everybody has
advice
yeah i was more of a close guy like
shellfish everyone has like a thing they
have a big shelf
i love like shrimp and you know you ever
have shellfish tower like a restaurant
like shrimp
seafood is my favorite yeah yeah clothes
in the beginning i i
was like it has to be louie it has to be
gucci but
it doesn't like a hoodie and a beanie
and skinny jeans right
[ __ ] shirt i do the polo i like
polo i just do it because it's just like
i just started wearing it and that's not
just what i wear and it's just
easy it's like a uniform and i just yeah
and that that's
this is kind of like a uniform too
because everybody it's like oh like what
do you expect each other for halloween
yeah they'll go as little as yeah just
put my face that's either they'll be
like you're a fat little sad
i'm like i'm little zan bad zam fat
well dude i [ __ ] appreciate an hour
went by like nothing oh you're [ __ ]
dude
it's wild to have you on yeah so great a
lot of my fans would be like very
interested in this conversation
i'm i'm like thrilled you're a fan of
the show i love it i'm
thrilled you [ __ ] like some of the
[ __ ] we do so sick i love that [ __ ]
uh that slingshot song that's like an
unofficial song of our
career i love a lot of the other stuff
you do i thought you were billy eilish
for many years
and now that i've finally realized i
finally realized
uh that you're not but dudes [ __ ]
you're so [ __ ] talented you're
so [ __ ] good thank you for having me
stay [ __ ] sober dude keep making
music
and we'll head up to saddle ranch and
we'll leave some chicken fingers all the
tick talkers all right brother thank you
for coming on dude
so much i appreciate that thank you man
tell everyone where they can find you if
they don't know they know
but uh instagram at zanziti just put an
x in front of the word anxiety and
basically that's it yeah
there you go all right everybody go get
the stoner burrito all right